well first of all congratulations for
being like the head of the first
club and this list um but first first
first it's got to be wonderful and
stressful
well you know my mother had many sayings
and one of them
she would often say is calmly you may be
the first to do many things make sure
you're not the last
exactly right and that's so much of what
your work has been awesome that's a lot
to carry for sure
i'm curious um we're so excited about
this list because there's so many of us
um and i'm just wondering when you were
in your 20s and 30s
did you ever imagine your career after
no i know but by that i mean i've never
thought of age
and i've never been one to do a five
year plan like literally
i like never so i haven't ever evaluated
myself based on
my age it's been based on a task
and that's really how i've kind of lived
you know i just i think that but i i
will say that i think that there is so
much
that um we still need to do to encourage
girls and women of every age
to to know and internalize their
capacity
and to internalize their
strength and their and their gift
whatever that may be
and um and to not be burdened
right by other people's limited views
of their capacity based on who has
historically done what exactly and pace
yourself
you got a long time do what you need to
do well and do what's in front of you
well and the next thing will come i mean
i
i i mentor a lot of young women and one
of the things that i
i believe and i say is you know figure
out
what kind of gives you you know your
brain
like a tingle the thing that you want to
read more or you want to debate it
the thing that would that makes you feel
something
because you're going to work hard
whatever you do but
if you have the luxury and it is a
blessing and
a luxury to be able to follow your
passion but if you can
follow your passion do that and the
other things will come
was there a point in your career where
you realized maybe you had a longer
runway
than you ever thought
no i mean no i i i
listen i am like i again
tell a lot of people i mentor i eat no
for breakfast
um so have i been told many times during
my career
things from oh you're too young it's not
your turn
they're not ready for you um
no one like you has done it before i've
heard all of those things many times
over
the course of my career but i didn't
listen and
i would encourage anyone who's been told
that
whatever their gender to not listen
because again
don't be encumbered by the inability of
others to see the potential
of who you are i eat no for breakfast
i didn't listen this sounds very male
and successful
that's awesome i i yeah but yes
i mean i just think that you ca it's
really important to recognize
the limitations that other people have
based on their expectations and and to
not impose that on on oneself well we
get set back by no's i think you get a
no and i think some women
take it a lot of them take it really
personally and i love that you eat them
for breakfast
because here's the thing here because
here's the piece of it that i that
is at its core who who has the authority
to tell you who you are
you know you don't let people tell you
who you are you tell
them who you are that's how i feel about
these things
and that's i think i think we have the
answer
minion moore submitted the nomination
for you
um forbes 50 over 50 list and
she wrote this vice president harris
believes that everyone no matter what
their circumstances in life may bring
deserve to be treated with dignity and
respect her vision is an america where
everyone sees themselves and everyone is
included
so with so many small businesses um
especially run by women shutting down
brutalized by the pandemic how do you
how do you envision
um getting access to capital to
marginalized entrepreneurs
i'm so glad you brought that up so this
is one of my
areas of focus i care so deeply about
this which is
one let's just let's just be clear about
where we are
half of america's workforce works for a
small business or owns a small business
um sadly during the course of the
pandemic one third of our small
businesses have closed
let's add on to this that if you lift up
the economic status of women you lift up
the economic status of families and all
of society benefits
okay and then let's talk about women on
small businesses women-owned small
businesses range
from the the child care center
to the software company and what i've
seen in my travels
is that women own small businesses many
of them like there's
these two women who are running a
restaurant once in a restaurant one's
running a catering business one's in
colorado one's in california
and i met with them they survived during
the pandemic and i said how did it go in
terms of starting out
when you had this vision and both of
them said
i heard a word i'd never heard before i
was told i was
unbankable so they went to a bank
to start their business and they were
told that they were unbankable that they
basically were not worth
the investment and so what ended up
happening is both of them
found a way to actually have people who
believe in them
and one of the things that we should do
more of is investing community banks
called cdfis
which are in the community and have the
ability because they're in the community
to see the vision of these incredible
entrepreneurs
so that's some of the work i'm doing um
and i've met
community banks cdfi's there's a one
that's run in south dakota that's
focused on the
the native american community there um
and the
the bank or the run the person who runs
the small business which is a community
bank
said you know there are native americans
in the community who have
a vision for opening a an operation to
make quilts
because ceremonial quilts quilts for
special occasion
people buy those they want them there's
a market for it
and they may go to a traditional bank to
get the investment
the traditional bank doesn't see the
vision right but the community bank does
so i'm focused on
working with community banks to make
sure that women entrepreneurs
who have a vision that
they're that they are respected and they
can go to a place that they give they
receive dignity
um that believes in their vision their
vision and invest in it and they can be
bankable and they are bankable
um i'm thinking of the women over 50
especially who have been
um forced into early retirement yeah who
don't want to be done
who can't afford to be done no that's
right uh what what do you say to them
and what can businesses and government
do to help
these women well there's a lot i mean
first of all
there is the whole issue of right to
return
right i so to your point um
i have spent a great deal of time
working with
women who work in the hospitality
industry culinary workers
hotel workers um in in
las vegas for example and a big issue
going on there
is that they were laid off during the
pandemic because of course there was no
business
but now they're fighting to get their
jobs back and
the older the woman the more fear she
has that she will not be rehired
and so there's a whole push for
legislation
and for for people to support those
women's
right to be able to return to work so
there has to be a perspective on behalf
of every branch of government
that recognizes these women lost their
jobs through no fault of their own
they should not be penalized for a
pandemic they did not create
and they absolutely should not be
penalized for their age because by the
way they bring experience to the job and
they have an investment
in the work they've been doing for in
many cases a couple of decades
and they've got many decades to go
absolutely how do you define inclusive
capitalism how do you think it can be
um it can address the most pressing
issues
um especially equality of opportunity
specifically regarding gender race and
ethnicity age
and socio-economic background so
capitalism
in its best form is about
the the beauty of competition
to create the greatest product to create
the greatest
outcome but inherent in that
is an assumption that everyone starts
out on the same base
and then they compete and whoever wins
wins the market
right the market share but that's a
false assumption
when you take into account the fact that
not everyone comes
starts from the same place in particular
when we take into account race and
gender
so what we have to do is recognize the
disparities that have long exist
and existed and and take that into
consideration
when we want to encourage competition
and that includes for example what i'm
doing around
women-owned small businesses
minority-owned small businesses
and giving people equal access to
compete
that at its core will produce the best
outcome for all for the customer for
society
for our economy and in the interest of
of of the best of what capitalism
should encourage and create what's your
advice to women in their 20s and 30s who
feel like they have to pack it all in
who are stressed who are like
feel like there's a clock ticking and
that there's like a
time shelf on their life
one um continue with your ambition
and don't be don't apologize for it
and continue to believe that you
can do whatever you want to do
but also know you have a right to expect
things like affordable child care you
have a right to expect
paid family leave when you need to take
care of your children
or your elderly parents that you have a
right to resp
to expect that you will be seen in the
full dimension of who you are and your
responsibilities
and that they should be supported these
things can coexist so what i say then
do not accept false choices that you
have to choose either this thing or that
thing
that's a false choice don't accept it
and finally and this is the most
important question and hope everyone's
listening
if you're watching morning joe yeah is
it joe
willy or mika it's mika
[Laughter]
thank you so much madam vice president
it's great to be with you mate thank you
congratulations
thank you